submarines are supposed to be totally
undetectable that's their whole ml they
sneak around the world's oceans being
undetectable they carry nuclear weapons
but one way that adversaries try to find
submarines is through magnets because
submarines are giant hunks of metal you
can fly one of these little airplanes
over the ocean looking for some magnetic
field coming from the sub this is not
good submarines need to stay selfie oh
and did I mention that there are these
underwater mines that look like they
should be in some video game they
respond to magnetism so if a submarine
is sneaking in its enemies Waters and it
floats next to one of these mines it
could trip to mine if it's giving out
too much magnetism so the Navy's
solution the magnetism car wash before
the subs go out on deployment they run
it through this like car wash thing and
they get rid of all the magnetism and
sort of magnetic field fingerprints to
make it way less likely to be detectable
and then they go out on their way I've
been deep in submarines because we just
made this super long video and it's a
super deep dive in summer deep dive I
just said deep dive when talking about
submarines
yep I'm gonna sign off now